now we have this clip from the culture
War podcast where I was having
conversation with Emma vigilind of the
majority report co-host and considering
what we saw with this Pride event I I
want to play this clip and and discuss
it more in in in depth so I'm going to
play it for you now here we go you're
the one arguing for uh you're the one
arguing for censorship yes I mean I
don't I don't really mind that stuff I
mean do you are you in favor of children
seeing violence on television no it
scares me a little bit it depends
depends it's not so simple to save
violence right
um but yes censorship is a good thing
but when done bad is a bad thing yeah uh
for instance uh Ian Crossland who is a
co-host on Tim cast IRL used to be a
moderator for mines.com and he had to
filter out graphic depictions of murder
and and rape and child abuse censorship
is absolutely vital in in that in that
regard so if we're talking about a book
like uh in particular there was one
called there was a teacher Who provided
a book to her middle schoolers called
this book is gay I don't know if you've
ever heard of it I have heard that's a
very good book and it provides
instruction on children she provided
instruction to children on how to use
adult gay anonymous sex apps yeah I
don't think that's appropriate now look
by all means you can be in favor
maybe maybe she had a child in her
classroom who wanted to go on Grindr and
have sex with adults is that your
argument no I mean I'm not saying that
first of all I don't know again this is
a 10 year old need grinder this is this
this is the thing that you do though
you're picking specific examples
you asked me for one okay then go ahead
yeah I'm I'm I said don't show children
blow jobs I'm not in favor of censorship
this book is gay he's a book
that teaches the individual reading it
how to use adult sex apps and
holy crap there are things described in
that book that
you know
I can't even I can't even describe I'm
buying it I can't even bro you gotta
have it on the table oh you're buying
the book right I don't disagree with
that I don't like giving these people
money but I think it's important to know
and for people to read this stuff but
the book describes things that go well
beyond uh uh sex and kink into what I
would describe as dangerous behavior
that can result in serious uh
uh look when they talk about consuming
feces and there's and it goes beyond
that wow I'm like you're talking about
things that can cause serious harm to a
person let alone a child when she says
it's a great book and defends the idea
that children would get it I have to
wonder
I almost don't have to wonder it's a
question of do we really think these
people just don't know what they're
talking about or does she actually does
does Emma actually want children to have
sex with adults Emma had one thing on
her mind when she came in here and that
was disagree with Tim Poole there was
not any brain function going on she was
just what does Tim Poole say challenge
it because maybe maybe dude but she's an
idiot no no maybe but that's giving them
the benefit of the doubt when they're
trying to get kids on Grindr no no how
progressives view all of this right like
the patriarchy they want to tear all
that down but they they want to progress
beyond all institutions barriers they
think that laws that protect children
from sex is actually hurting them so
right it's causing them harm like that's
what the academics and ideologues of
progressivism believe yes Emma is not
that Emma is not like like she is not
she's like her head is so empty and that
like the whole point of her coming here
was to get something that and the same
thing goes for like the moon
Minority Report or whatever majority
report they're they're just they're just
looking to to to dunk on Tim pool she
came here hoping to get some kind of way
to dunk on Tim pool sir now you're right
there are people that know Theory and
actually believe it's good to to have
intergenerational uh relationships
people like Herbert Marcus and and you
know uh Gail Rubin I think is their name
and and the the people that write queer
Theory books you're totally right Emma's
not one of them Emma is a useful idiot
that's why she was was like screaming
about supporting
uh trans women in women's sports because
even if it hurts some of the competitors
you're saying you're saying I'm a Vega
lens advocacy for pedophilia isn't that
she herself is a pedophile but that she
stands opposed to yes like institutions
laws and and anything on the right
anything that comes out of your mouth
she's going to oppose she had no idea I
will say this the reason why I can't
agree with that
is you for what I don't want to give
them the benefit of the doubt because I
I think they know exactly what they're
talking about but for her maybe she she
did this thing where she after the show
she claimed she wasn't cool enough to
see the skate park it's the weirdest
thing in the world because I I said
earlier
maybe when she pulled up and parked she
didn't notice she was in a skate park
because the front of the property is the
skate park yeah and I'm like maybe she
they pulled up into the far space and
just walked right in the green room door
and she didn't notice because she didn't
look anywhere then I found out from
staff she was actually right in the
middle of it she she was standing in the
middle of the skate park there's ramps
everywhere there's rails and Ledges you
can see everything there's like a big
speaker for music and then she called
and said I didn't get to see the skate
park and I'm like that's a really weird
thing to lie about literally trip over
the grinding rail that is right at the
front of the house if you're not careful
you will fall over that she was talking
about the other skate park the
downstairs one that's what I think it
was anyway I'm not here dude downstairs
is a mini ramp not a skate park she was
the skate park is the is the is the the
barn and the there's a there's a massive
24 foot long vert wall it's it's a it's
a an eight-foot vert uh eight foot wide
vert and then there's a 20-foot or a 16
foot four uh four foot section
you park right in front of it and you're
surrounded by ramps it's it's a weird
thing to lie about she could have said
well I did get I did get to see the
skate park I didn't get to see their
ramp though I could see how it might not
look like a skate park because there's a
bunch of cars parked all around it
because it's a parking lot as well it's
doubles as a parking lot you might not
have realized she was in one you're so
kind yeah she literally so she was
offered a tour Sushi and poker with the
boys when the show rabbit said we're all
gonna hang out we're gonna we're gonna
uh we have sushi that's here bubble tea
cheeseburgers we put on some music we
had the table we play a micro stakes
poker game basically poker for fun not
for money and uh we can show you around
he goes no I can't I've got to run and
I'm like okay cool thanks for coming and
what does she do they wouldn't show me
anything well she called Sam and they
were they were joking I mean she's
pretty clear like Tim this is like High
School drama but I think it was so that
one but it wasn't it was so that way she
could slime like the people here yeah it
wasn't it wasn't like a haha Tim it
wasn't a good nature joke it wasn't
because of cause she wanted to be
humorous and and be fun it was a way to
slime Tim and her experience here even
though Tim was polite kind and and
exactly what Sam Cedar did exactly when
we invited him on the show I said I know
exactly what he's going to do it's low
tier WWE political garbage and if I
invite him on the show they do this
thing where all of a sudden abruptly
they'll say something in a non-sequitur
and you're confused by what they're
saying because they she she had on her
computer I uh my understanding is that
she was being told what to say oh really
in the middle of the conversation well
she she had a list of things like
written at your point that she's like
just vacuous yeah that's an assumption
man she's a journalist she reads like 50
pages a day before she works look at
look at what happened with Stephen
Crowder and Sam Cedar right Stephen
Crowder was gonna have a conversation
with Ethan Klein and then Sam barges in
and then starts just clucking like a
chicken like just bock bock nonsense
because it's WWE to them so so I'm like
we can have her on the show and I said
it would be with another person to
discuss ideas so we got Sean Fitzgerald
and what does she do before the show we
were like hey let's open with crime and
talk about Jordan Williams this guy in
New York who's you know he was a black
guy people are saying he's not getting
the same support as uh uh Penny because
he's black and she goes yeah of course
absolutely as soon as the show starts
what does she do e-drama WWE garbage I
think uh majority report primarily is
like a comedy show slash it's more like
The Daily Show like that so let me let
me finish please uh and it's the whereas
this shows more serious and I think they
both Sam and Emma get get a kick out of
making you upset like it's just part of
like the pushing your friends around
hold up this is not no no I'm I'm
stopping I'm sorry this is not me being
like oh I can't believe I got dunked on
it this is Emma advocating for
pedophilia no it's not she's gonna cut
her off at a minute and five I was
watching this clip I watched the show
live you cut her off at a minute and
five in the clip and didn't let her talk
about what she said maybe the teacher
has a student in her class vets and you
cut her off and that was the end of it
she couldn't explain herself what watch
the full episode I did I watched it once
yeah no she goes into greater detail we
talked for like 20 minutes about how she
was like she explicitly said she did not
care if 10 year olds were shown
I think she's out of line
they're having a show where they
advocate for pedophilia at a time where
they're chanting we're coming for your
children and they produced A 50-person
Chorus called we're coming for your
children Ian take the blinders off
that's what I'm saying I think there's a
blind there's blindness in people's
brains where they think that things have
happened so slowly as they're
introducing sexuality to Children
nine-year-olds seeing porn and things
that now people are like why do we
censorship is the bad guy we don't need
just let things happen naturally and
like dude it's our duty and
responsibility to create a moral system
we don't stay on it every day it's gonna
go haywire when has the left ever been
against censorship
for her to be like I oppose censorship
it's like oh please they they complain
that someone says a naughty word on the
internet they want them all banned then
when it comes to the issue of pedophilia
she's like I think she I'm not even I'm
not even a quota when it comes to the
issue of pedophilia and a teacher trying
to get her students of 10 years old to
use grinder she defends it there at
hiroshikura said she would have said
okay like yes that's bad but here's what
I'm saying she didn't say that dude for
for two two and a half hours we talk or
like two hours and 20 minutes and she's
in every respect defending that they're
doing these things in every respect and
then it got to the point where I was
like I don't understand and it's
probably like Phil said whatever it is
we agree whatever it is we agree on no
matter what they oppose no matter what
so I'm like why I was like isn't it in
your interest to have Joe Biden like out
to get somebody else so when we come out
we're like hey here's evidence Joe
Biden's corrupt shouldn't you just be
like oh and she's like no it's not true
and I'm like oh wait wait what no it is
true reactionarianism you got to watch
out for that stuff anyone that's willing
to refute what you say because they
don't like you is a that's a big problem
that's what the left is right now a lot
of sides can can fall into that and I've
been explaining this for a while the
left as we describe it is a reactionary
movement what does that mean reactionary
doesn't mean you react to something it
is a specific reference to those who are
trying to bring back or preserve the old
ways that is what the left is doing when
they they're not about progress This Is
A Lie when when you get ibram candy
coming out and saying the only solution
to pass discrimination Etc et cetera
when he's basically advocating for
future discrimination
Derek uh Derek Bell I think I'm hoping
I'm not getting his name wrong they're
advocating for returning to Plessy V
Ferguson they want to bring back the old
before the Civil Rights Movement they
are reactionaries who are upset we had a
civil libertarian revolution in this
country that brought about individual
rights they are collectivists they hate
that we've enshrined in our constitution
individual rights and they want to turn
back the clock to get rid of that
they're reactionaries now you're right
as for Emma maybe it is fair to say no
matter what it is you advocate for she
will be against if I say hey look here's
evidence Joe Biden's cryptos I'm like
but you hate you it's personal Tim it
was all about like there after it was
personal about you that I mean anybody
that was here obviously would have been
a representative of Tim Cass but like
the whole thing was they want Clips they
were hoping to get Clips but Emma was
just incapable of producing something
that would be compelling for them other
than oh he didn't show me his uh his his
skate park I wonder if they feel I I
kind of felt like Emma felt a little bit
of shame because I know that the thing
she said about Neo-Nazi she was told to
say probably by Sam and afterwards when
the Show wrapped you know and she steps
out of the room for a bit we are all
talking about it about this is the issue
with the majority report the Sam Cedar
is blacklisted from a bunch of big
networks and podcasts he got fired from
MSNBC I think I think and this is
explicitly why as has been iterated to
me by a lot of people that he's an
unserious person who just tries to
gamify people for for bad faith politics
and then you know as she's walking back
in the room uh Sean was like oh the
Neo-Nazi thing is out of line it's like
it's not a real debate it's not a real
political argument it's just an
intentionally destructive to the
political space and then she like is
looking down she wouldn't look as look
as in the eyes at all the whole time I
wonder like she had made a big stink
about uh the amount of money that they
don't make and didn't want to admit that
it's because there's not really an
audience for it or not the same kind of
audience
um she did mention like you'd said
earlier one of the things that I wanted
to push back on she said over and over
that she was covering serious political
topics and et cetera
um and I think that all all of the
majority report and her in particular
but I would assume that the feeling is
shared with most of the people over
there is just massive jealousy they
don't get invited up to Capitol Hill
they're not they're not streaming their
show from Congress you know from
congressional people's offices they're
not they don't have the same kind of uh
reach they don't get the same kind of
reaction uh from from audiences and
stuff so I think but that's that you're
right but that's like saying the people
who intentionally choose not to shower
are surprised that people don't want
them around absolutely and that's
exactly how people behave I've smelled
plenty of stinky people like they people
get people don't know that their breath
stinks or that they're that they're
offensive to other people that their
ideas are or they they behave in ways
that you know push people away if people
realize that there probably wouldn't be
any incel she was saying that they that
Sam is like a comedian first he's not
really his primary focus is in business
jokes too what they need you what they
need is a 10 a month subscription like
they need to load because they've got
1.3 million subscribers or something
majority report those like you guys can
monetize big time get 20 000 subscribers
a month 15 000 whatever you know you're
gonna be you're gonna be fine you know I
enjoy telling people that they did that
it was about the politics and it wasn't
for money and da da da da she loved like
she was reveling in pointing out that
she was morally Superior that was one of
the things that was really so gross
about it she came here and and had this
air of superiority and we're better than
you and we're blah blah blah just and it
was just I found it you know you know
what I think the majority report I think
they're like the the incel equivalent of
politics
where like
you get you get a guy who's out of shape
not really not doesn't have good social
skills says crude and rude things smells
bad and has a poor diet and then they
get really jealous that people don't
want to be friends with them so they go
online they get really angry and start
talking about how the world sucks and
how bad it is
and I think that's what the majority
report is because you know you can have
you have this big political space with a
whole bunch of different commentators of
different various backgrounds all having
debates and you know and getting along
to varying degrees and then you have the
majority report where Sam gets like
banned from a bunch of different shows
then complains about it and then when
people bring up that he's banned what
did Emma say she's like well it's
because they're scared of them it's like
part of it and because he's a dick she
was no one's scared of him dude it's
probably both it's literally not it's
because well Destiny is he's straight
upset if there's anyone on the left I
would that's fine if Destiny said that
but but and I and I think Sean mentioned
that but I can tell you this
definitively because I've talked to many
prom like many big networks and stuff
they've explicitly said they think he's
just going to come and and clown them
like he's not he's not a real he's not a
serious person it's a clown show it's
it's the you know the WWE of of politics
you're gonna get this phase he was an
actor thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a remember over at timcast.com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time